[Music]
oh we're having some fun here at the
commercial break this morning in our
special series the work shift on how
work has changed during the pandemic we
are talking with jobless americans
jobless by choice it's why they are
still unemployed many businesses
businesses are saying they're having a
tough time fi hiring new people and the
numbers show that there are about 10
million job openings nationwide and
officially about 8.7 million americans
who are without a job we wanted to find
out why some have not rejoined the
workforce and we spoke with priscissa
bell or priscilla bell rather in seattle
aaron davison in orlando and natasha
bengeli in gilbert south carolina also
matthew taylor of ithaca new york take a
look
i worked as a bartender and server i've
been a fitness professional for 40 years
i was a personal caregiver housekeeper i
worked part time as a turnstiles
attendant the health pandemic has become
a financial pandemic i've been
unemployed for almost two years now
since march 15 of 2020 in april of
since the 2020
of lockdown more than 6.6 million
americans filed unemployment claims last
week i had like five months worth of
savings that was gone i was gone so
early businesses are opening
restaurants are reopening
it presents a challenge
to care give for my mother
to return to work
and to provide for my family to not put
my mother at risk
or vulnerability towards covent
businesses across the country are
desperately looking for workers people
are not hiring back for group exercise
classes they're going very slowly
i can't even go look for work right now
the schools are lacking bus drivers we
haven't even gotten the option to have a
bus come pick our daughter up my only
option is to drive her there and pick
her up every day so far at least 11 gop
governors are pulling out of a program
mr biden implemented that raised
unemployment checks by 300 bucks a week
our cost of living is ridiculous and i i
could never live off in point
unemployment i mean it's kind of a
desperate situation i don't even get
enough money to pay rent on unemployment
now it's not just a matter of luxury
it's the fact that these jobs aren't
paying enough to eat and pay rent